مرحبًا Facebook أنا بن ويدمان من CNN
هنا في بيروت لبنان أنا
مراسل الشبكة هنا
وما كان يجري في الوقت الحالي هل
هناك احتجاجات عنيفة في هذا
الشارع الرئيسي في بيروت عاصمة لبنان
هذا هو شارع الحمرا الذي  هي
منطقة تجارية رئيسية تحولت هذا المساء
إلى منطقة قتال الآن هذه
الاحتجاجات مستمرة في لبنان
منذ 17 أكتوبر ، وهو اليوم 90
من الاحتجاج الذي اندلع في
البداية بعد أن فرضت الحكومة
أو قالت إنها ستذهب  فرض
ضريبة على ما هو جديد ، وهو الأمر الأساسي الذي هو
السبيل الوحيد الذي يمكن للناس من خلاله
التواصل هنا بهذه الطريقة الاقتصادية
منذ ذلك الحين رأينا الحكومة قد
سقطت نتيجة لهذه
الاحتجاجات والاقتصاد في حالة من التراجع الحر للبطالة.
يتم طردهم
من العمل ، يتقاضى الآخرون نصف
رواتبهم فقط ، وبعضهم لا شيء على الإطلاق ، واليوم هذا
الأسبوع هو ما يسمى بأسبوع
الغضب ،
لا توجد حكومة لبنانية فعالة
مثلك  يمكن أن يرى فقط
لإعطائك فكرة عما يحدث هنا ،
فهذه حاويات قمامة
أضرمت فيها النيران وُضعت في منتصف
الشارع الآن يتحرك رجال الشرطة المناسبون
للأمام ، ما تراه أمامي هو
شاحنة محمولة على عدة  قاذفة الغاز المسيل للدموع
وما رأيناه لم
يكن عملاً حتى الآن ، لكن ما
رأيناه في الساعات القليلة الماضية هو أن الشرطة المناسبة
أطلقت عشرات وعشرات من
طلقات الغاز المسيل للدموع على المتظاهرين.
لعبة القط والفأر مع شرطة مكافحة الشغب في
وقت سابق رأينا بعض المتظاهرين
يستخدمون طفايات الحريق وإشارات التوقف
لتحطيم نوافذ البنوك ،
وبالطبع كانت البنوك محور غضب
العديد من هؤلاء الناس هنا جيدًا.  لقد
سمعت قبطان شرطة مكافحة الشغب
يقول إنهم بحاجة إلى مزيد من التعزيزات
لأن هذا ليس المكان الوحيد الذي
تدور فيه الاحتجاجات على الرغم من أنه من الواضح أن هذا
هو المكان الذي تحدث فيه الاحتجاجات الأكثر عنفًا
والأهمية التي تحدث كما قلت
خلال الساعات القليلة الماضية ، بدأ العنف الحقيقي
أمام المخبأ الذي سيولد
وهو البنك المركزي للبنان
حيث حاول بعض المتظاهرين
تجاوز الحواجز ، ستظهر الحواجز
التي أقيمت حول البنك المركزي
هنا.
أصيب رجل شرطة مكافحة الشغب هذا
لأن أول المتظاهرين يرمون
العديد من الحجارة على شرطة مكافحة الشغب هنا
، فلننتقل قليلاً إلى واحدة أخرى من
حاويات القمامة هذه ، حيث
يتواجد المتظاهرون بشكل أساسي في الشوارع الجانبية
وفي أعلى الشارع.  بدلاً من
ذلك ، يقول القبطان لقواته أن
يبتعدوا عن المتظاهرين ومن
الواضح أنهم غارقون إلى حد
ما في الأرقام الموجودة هنا الآن أعتقد أنني
أتلقى بعض الأسئلة هنا يسأل شخص ما
لماذا يغضب الناس جيدًا يغضب الناس
لأنهم يشعرون  أن
النظام السياسي هنا الذي يقوم
على هذا التقسيم للسلطة حسب
الجنس بين المسلمين الشيعة السنة
الدروز ومجموعات مختلفة من مجلس حقوق الإنسان.  الاستيطانيون في
لبنان 18 طائفة معترف بها
والمشكلة هي أن العديد من الناس العاديين
يشعرون أن النخبة السياسية كانت ببساطة
تثري نفسها على مدى كل هذه
السنوات ولا تفعل سوى القليل لحل
معدلات البطالة المرتفعة في البلاد
ومعدلات النمو الاقتصادي المنخفضة ،
والبنية التحتية في حالة سيئة
و  بيروت قبل هذه الأزمة ، كان هناك
انقطاع يومي للتيار الكهربائي لمدة ثلاث ساعات في
أجزاء أخرى من لبنان بما يصل إلى 14 ساعة في
اليوم في الأسابيع الأخيرة ، زاد انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
هنا في بيروت - خمس ست
ساعات وسبع ساعات في اليوم أحيانًا
وبالطبع للتعويض عن ذلك.  قلة القوة ،
يدفع الناس أكثر من 100 دولار للمولدات الكهربائية ،
لذلك هناك الكثير من الغضب ، إنه ببساطة
سوء إدارة لهذا البلد ، دعونا نرى
أين سؤال آخر ، حسنًا ، ماذا
عن التوترات مع نعم إيران والتأثير على
لبنان بشكل جيد ، بالطبع
لبنان يشبه اندلاع نوع من
التدريس فيه  هذه الحرب الإقليمية بالوكالة
بين الولايات المتحدة وإيران ،
تدعم إيران حزب الله الذي يعد واحدًا من
أفضل السياسيين تنظيماً والأكبر.
الأحزاب هنا والولايات المتحدة
تعارض ذلك ، فقد فرضت الولايات المتحدة
عقوبات على أعضاء مختلفين من
مؤسسات حزب الله المختلفة والتي
تقول الولايات المتحدة إنها تهدف إلى الضغط
على بيلا ، ولكن في كثير من الأحيان كما هو الحال
مع العقوبات ، فإنها تضر بالناس العاديين
أكثر من هؤلاء.  من لديه القوة بالفعل ،
لذا فإن لبنان جزء كبير من
الحرب بالوكالة التي نراها هنا ،
دعونا نحاول الانتقال إلى منطقة أخرى ،
حسنًا ، شخص ما يقول كم الساعة
هنا الساعة 10:25 مساءً  في بيروت لا يوجد
حظر تجول كما ترى لا توجد محاولة
لفرض حظر تجول لأن ضع في اعتبارك
أن هذا جزء من بيروت.
المدينة بأكملها عندما نأمل حدوث الحوادث
ومناطق محدودة فقط
ويقول أحدهم هل هذا جزء مركزي
من المدينة ، إنه أحد
الأجزاء المركزية للمدينة لديك مناطق مختلفة
ولكن HMDA
يعود إلى سنوات عديدة كان شارعًا
لدور السينما  والمسارح والمقاهي
والحانات والمطاعم في ذروة لبنان
قبل اندلاع
الحرب الأهلية في 13 أبريل 1975 ، كانت الحرب الأهلية بالفعل
القلب الثقافي لبيروت منذ ذلك الحين
بالطبع خمسة عشر عامًا من الاضطرابات الاقتصادية للحرب الأهلية
أدت إلى حد ما إلى تقليص مكانة الحمادة.
في الماضي الآن يبدو الأمر بالنسبة
لي حيث ذهبوا
قليلاً مشوهًا رائعًا هناك قساوسة K
لديهم تاريخ من هذا للانضمام إلى
جيلبرت
شيرلوك حسنًا.  ويسأل ما الذي يجب تغييره
لإعادة لبنان إلى قدميه هو
تغيير النظام ، الجواب جيد يخبرك باستمرار أن
لبنان ليس نظامًا ، إنه
منتخب ديمقراطيًا لديه
حكومة منتخبة ديمقراطيًا
والطريقة التي يغير بها الناس الحكومة
هنا هي انتخابات حقيقية  الآن كما
أوضحت منذ فترة وجيزة مع كون
التقسيم الطائفي للسلطة الموجود
هنا في لبنان هو أساس
السياسة ، فإنه يجعل من الصعب
تغيير هذا النظام ولكن تغيير النظام في
الحقيقة ليس مطروحًا هنا ولا
أحد يرغب في ذلك.  ليس لدينا
حكومة خالية من الفساد ، فهي
تخدم الناس بدلاً من
السياسيين ، وهم يرغبون في مستقبل
يحاول العديد من الأشخاص الذين أتحدث إليهم هنا
الخروج من البلاد لأنهم
ببساطة لا يرون أي أمل لأنفسهم أو
لأطفالهم  ومأساة
لبنان هي أن هذا بلد
عالمي متقدم تعليما عاليا جدا
ولعنه حكومة وسياسية فاسدة وغير كفؤة بشكل مروع.
يرى النظام والكثير من الناس هذه
الحركة الاحتجاجية التي كانت مستمرة
الآن نحن في اليوم 90 ، دعونا
نقترب قليلاً لنرى ما يحدث هنا ،
نرى أن حركة الاحتجاج هذه هي حقًا
أملهم الأخير ومحاولة تغيير
النظام  للأفضل
لأنه في الوقت الحالي لا يعمل مع
الأشخاص العاديين